four guiding principles will underpin
our strategy stability fairness
productivity and sustainability let me
begin with economic stability which is
precondition for economic growth and
transformation fiscal policies need to
be responsible and appropriately
differentiated leading to sound and
sustainable public finances in line with
a commonly agreed rules differentiate
fiscal policies means that countries
which shall fiscal space are invited to
continue using it now but those whose
high debt levels should bring it down
the second principle we need to focus on
making alcohol is to make our economies
more productive by embracing technology
and digitalization we need to change
outdated economic structure so we can
become a global leader in an
increasingly digitalized world and
harness great creative potential what
Europe has so you know ITU countries to
step up the reform efforts and Paulo
will go into more detail regarding the
SiC the situation of macroeconomic
imbalances
they're also working together on a
sustainable Europe investment plan which
will provide dedicated financing for
sustainable investments in every part of
the EU but none of this can happen
without Europe having a shared
understanding of what green economic
activity it's so I welcomes a
breakthrough between EU colleges laters
last night on vital legislation to
create a green list or taxonomy of
sustainable economic activities this
piece of legislation is crucial for the
Green Deal to become a reality it will
enable green investments to flow reach
scale and help Europe reach climate
neutrality by 2050 the fourth principle
in our economic strategy is fairness be
a greener digital we need to put people
at the heart of the transitions so no
person and no region should be left
behind there is a big upside because if
managed well the green and digital
transitions can create many jobs and a
healthy working and living environment
these transitions can actually help to
deliver on the social pillar and put
Europe as a competitive advantage in
comparison to other regions in the world
these recommendation provides direction
for policies affecting the euro area as
a whole because we need to think of the
euro area as one economic entity in need
of great coordination of course
coordination doesn't mean uniformity the
challenging facing euro area countries
remain very diverse this is clearly
reflected in our call for member states
with current account deficits to boost
complete competitiveness and reduce
their external debt and for those with
large current account surpluses to
support wage growth and foster
investment
we also call all the euro area countries
in this recommendation to support and
implement actions to combat aggressive
tax planning and address a race to the
bottom in corporate taxation all
countries also need to strengthen their
the education and training systems and
boost investments in skills while
purchasing other reforms to make labour
markets more inclusive the good news is
that we are not proposing any in-depth
reviews for new countries our report
concludes that the same 13 member states
which underwent an in-depth review one
year ago should again be analyzed these
are Bulgaria Croatia Cyprus France
Germany Greece Ireland Italy the
Netherlands Portugal Romania Spain and
Sweden Mansilla Parvati avec le Senegal
Italy disparate a occupy Osada PE
persists the Senegalese a Diwali Oh Joe
acaba a gallop afar calificaciones era
el fondo no socity Soto's Omaha human
realism in octodome poetical malaria as
a we D as a realism to the year
initiative the red well as Evo say
despite a illegality dog avenue de Patri
mon OC avec des a car - Jacques Oh Oh
San Jose tomando illegality Alfa Talman
Vetrov a preschooler Trevino pepople
uh trabajo de Scania Casa de King Reaper
may Putin Pavel décimo say - nonso de la
mission plus ricardo police'll a minimum
a non separate resident a Kiska present
a a la mission a the Nova strategy
annual proving croissants grab a donkey
no veil done Oh direction economy social
the
say Kiriko silly comrades Premila
president von der Leyen la marche de
sociologie attack plane male passive
issue you so traded what social elite
controller some automatic along as more
Povey no hot so she al mundo para la
Nova V Appa solo see results
don't position just
Dabo possible arrest is model competence
new divided Korea
Azra convertir a perfection era complete
ours
Alfred expert a plan more la potential
deposition numeric ecologic oh sweet
zarayda transition day regional sector
elessedil video so Petruchio a pedagogue
ta kotesashi davao del e transition
psychological numeric le transformation
Kaizen plan Shalimar sedative are not
Robert es la de da de person not Juarez
de Sol abolish Mohammedanism not
protection social loser ombudsman
protection social appropriate excessive
lattice a fast little a mobility
professional